to say go today I'm going to talk about
using brain imaging and biomarkers for
diagnosis and investigation of
Alzheimer's disease especially about the
Alzheimer's disease neuroimaging
initiative for those of you who are not
that familiar with Alzheimer's disease
its associated with two proteins the
first is amyloid beta and the second is
tau and the disease leads to memory
dysfunction memory decline ultimately
producing dementia until recently the
Alzheimer's disease has been defined
clinically with autopsy confirmation and
it was not possible to definitively
diagnose the disease until we had
autopsy but today with some of the
biomarkers that I'm going to talk about
it's possible to determine whether
somebody has Alzheimer's disease in the
brain quite definitively in someone
who's alive currently there are no
effective treatments for Alzheimer's
disease some treatments are being
developed in clinical trials are
underway some of the treatments are
aimed at amyloid protein I'm going to
point to this just get used to using the
pointer some are aimed at amyloid some
are aimed at tau some treatments are
aimed at neuroprotection a decade ago
there was a lot of chaos in the field of
Alzheimer's disease biomarkers and as
various companies and laboratories were
developing potential treatments there
was a need for optimization and
standardization of biomarkers for
clinical trials so this led to the
Alzheimer's disease neuroimaging
initiative which has been a very large
project we've received over 140 million
dollars so far from the National
Institutes of Aging and other
Institute's of NIH which are listed and
we also received about thirty percent of
our funding from our industry
partners in addition to me I'm the
principal investigator you can see that
there are lots of other people who are
involved with this project two names are
listed here and I'm going to in the next
a few minutes and give you a lot more
descriptions of what's going on with
this with this project the Alzheimer's
disease neuroimaging initiative
otherwise called Adney was funded in
2004 it's continuing today and will run
at least another two and a half years
and we're planning a five-year renewal
app to that so hopefully we'll be going
at least eight or nine more years we've
enrolled as you can see a 300 and
Charlie used to using this clicker 350
normal subjects 150 subjects with
subjective memory complaints of 850
subjects with mild cognitive impairment
350 subjects with dementia due to
Alzheimer's disease so overall you can
see it's well over a thousand subjects
have been enrolled and they're all
followed watch to tinley at 57 sites
across the United States and Canada you
can see on the map the location of the
various sites the everybody gets a
clinical evaluation blood tests lumbar
puncture various cognitive tests to
measure memory function and other kinds
of brain functions various types of MRI
which I will describe two kinds of PET
scans of Florida oxy glucose PET scan
which measures brain metabolism and
amyloid pet pet scan which measures
brain amyloid one of our punctures are
done for measuring the a beta and tau
proteins in the cerebral spinal fluid
and we getting genetics and everybody
and I'll tell you a little more about
that one thing that makes this project
quite unique is that all of the data
from addie is in a public database and
you can see the URL here the URL is USC
/ Loney slaves ed and anybody can go to
this database get a username and
password sign the daily use agreement
and anybody can get all of the data all
of the raw data the images the clinical
data the cognitive data all of the
genetics that it's all available to any
of you anybody you know wants to
download the data and write papers
there's no embargo on the data which
means that if patient were scanned today
for example in about two weeks the MRI
scan would be up on that public database
so there's many many thousands of scans
of all types and data this link to the
scans and it's all quite well organized
so we encourage people to use the data
and write papers because that's that's
the point of the project so this next
slide shows pictures of a lot of the lot
of the types of MRI scans that are done
you can see we do t1-weighted scans for
brain structure we do t2-weighted scans
flair to measure white matter
hyperintensities in the brain diffusion
tensor imaging and then on the bottom
row arterial spin label perfusion MRI
resting state test three functional MRI
fluorodeoxyglucose PET scans and amyloid
PET scans these are all of these scans
are done on almost all of the subjects
although the DTI scans the ASL MRI scans
and the fMRI scans are vendor-specific
that is the DPI scans are acquired on
the philips scanners and the ASL scans
are acquired on semen scanners and the
fMRI scans are required on the GE
scanners whereas all of the other MRIs
the t1 t2 or player are acquired all
scanners and then everybody gets fdg-pet
and everybody gets amyloid pet this is a
picture of the hippocampal subfield so
we do a particular high-resolution scan
to parcel 8 the hippocampal subfields
this is a separate project funded by the
Alzheimer's Association and the you can
see from this little slide that says
manual labeling
you can draw the CA in dentate gyrus and
the ca1 filled the Civic ulam the
internal cortex and so forth and again
all of this data is available on the
lonely database so this next slide shows
some of the amyloid scans that we've
been getting some examples and on the
top is a pimp Pittsburgh compound B
which was the first PET scan using
carbon 11 which was able to detect
amyloid in the living human brain and
below that is floor bait appear which is
now widely and commercially available
and the top two rows are on a normal
healthy control so you can see it was
kind of a bluish or greenish color there
in the brain whereas the lower two rows
or pip scans and floor beta P or scans
on a patient with Alzheimer's disease
you can see there's a lot of red there
especially in the outer parts of the
brain where the gray matter is showing
that amyloid protein was detected there
in abundance in this patient also on the
far left you'll see these numbers point
nine four below pip at one point 01
under floor mat appear and then 2.17 and
2.01 and those numbers refer to the
total uptake throughout the whole brain
reference to a region in the back of the
brain and we tend to use these numbers
for a measure of the total brain amyloid
so this next slide is a very important
slide because it is a histogram of the
distribution of these amyloid PET scans
with floormate appear this data is now a
year old we have quite a bit more data
now and unfortunately I'm having trouble
getting this thing to click and we try
something again i'm unable to point to a
columns here so i'm just going to have
to describe it the normal the normal
people across the top of this you see a
histogram it's as normal and 263 you can
see that the the bars are highest to the
far left of that graph where it says
FloorMate appear- and you can see a
horizontal line that tends to separate
that cluster of subjects from clusters
which are more to the right which are
floor beta p r+ so what that means is
that normal people are largely I'm away-
they don't have a lot of amyloid in
their brains these are people about
average age about 73 but there are quite
a few people that are to the right of
the line that is they have em within the
brain which means that they have
Alzheimer's disease they have plaques
and most likely they have tangles but
these are normal people so we call that
pre clinical Alzheimer's disease that is
they are people who are healthy they
don't have a problem but they have
amyloid pathology in their brain and as
we'll see there is greater risk for some
problems in the future if you go to the
bottom where it says ad on the right end
of 146 you'll see that most of those
people are to the right of that vertical
line and not too many of them are to the
left of the protocol line so that means
that most patients with Alzheimer's
disease clinically have a lot of a void
in their brain but it also points out
that a fair number of people diagnosed
with Alzheimer's disease clinically
don't seek that have amyloid in the
brain and we think that means they
probably don't have amyloid pathology
they probably don't have Alzheimer's
disease even though it was diagnosed
clinically if you then look at the late
MCI and early MCI populations you can
see that they have a big distribution
some of them they have people that have
a lot of amyloid but there's also bars
on the left especially in the early MCI
where there's a lot of those people who
are amyloid negative so MCI doesn't
necessarily mean that you have early
Alzheimer's disease what about sixty
percent of patients with MCI seem to
have early Alzheimer's disease and we'll
see more about that in the next slide so
this is longitudinal plots that
basically are making the point here
what we're doing is that we're plotting
the the ADA s cog score as a function of
time and we're looking at the slopes for
people who are a void negative or who
are fdg negative on the bottom and those
who are employed positive or fdg
positive on the top so just look at
those two plots on the right one on the
upper and one on the lower and you can
see the upper one ever says floor beta
for your positive zero point nine points
for your greater decline that means that
the people who had MCI who had my dinner
brain detected by clavate appear had a
greater cognitive decline than people
who did not have amyloid in the brain
and this is a theme that you're going to
hear from me throughout and and in the
end whole Alzheimer's field if you have
Emily in your brain you really have
Alzheimer's disease pathology in your
brain and you are a much greater risk to
show signs of cognitive decline here's
another example of from the normal
subjects this is from 72 normal subjects
if you just look on the right you'll see
that the people the lower right people
that are for beta P or negative and at
49 their their cognition is
longitudinally is a flat horizontal line
as a function of time but if you look at
the upper right you see that they're a
task Cox scores and going up and in this
case a higher a desk I've score means
you have a problem so the patients who
have Emma Lloyd in the brain who are
completely normal are showing a greater
rate of cognitive decline than the
normal people you don't have amyloid in
their brain suggesting that that I void
is doing something that's not good and
that these people are at future risk
that more decline and run into problems
the next slide here is from a different
study with Simon astray it's called able
and it basically shows you the risk of
having a positive amyloid scan so if you
look over on the right where it says MCI
and of 87
you see that those people who are
positive there are 60 subjects there who
are positive and they converted a
seventy seven percent of the MCI
patients where amyloid positive
converted to Alzheimer's disease in
three years we're only thirty-three
percent of the people who are negative
converted that Alzheimer's disease in
three years clinically and if you look
at the controls the controls who are
Emaline positive 25 percent of them
converted the MCI that would look like
early Alzheimer's disease in three years
whereas the negative that was only one
subject so once again a different study
but more evidence that having amyloid in
your brain is associated with more rapid
decline well another way to assess the
amount of Alzheimer's pathology in the
brain is to do a lumbar puncture
otherwise known as the spinal tap and
measure the proteins a beta and tau in
the brain and you can see that if you go
to the lower column where it says NC if
you look at a beta 1 2 42 it's 206 and
then you can see if you look at the
upper where it says ad the a beta what
the 42 is dropped to 143 so a beta goes
down in the cerebral spinal fluid as a
beta accumulates in plaques in the brain
and it's thought that perhaps the a beta
is sticking to the plaques which is why
it's concentrations are going down the
cerebral spinal fluid in contrast to a
reduction of a beta in CSF is the tau
going up from 70 in the canoe NC which
of the normal controls to 122 in the a
beta excuse me in the Alzheimer's
disease subjects so we see a pattern
here of CSF cerebral spinal fluid I'm
going beta protein going down and tau
proteins going up and there are the
measurements you get from CSF are quite
a concordance they agree with it
measures you get from amyloid scanning
so if you want to assess amyloid in the
brain you can use either PET scanning or
cerebral spinal fluid a beta
measurements of the advantage
getting a pet scan is that you don't
have to have a lumbar puncture I mean
lumbar punctures are not a big deal
they're not particularly painful but
some people are reluctant to have them
so that's one reason to do a scan you
don't have to have a lumbar puncture and
it appears to be easier to standardize
the scan measurements then the essays by
in this frugal spinal fluid but I on
white scans are costly and you don't get
any information about tau if you do a
lumbar puncture if you do a lumbar
puncture you can measure a beta you can
miss your tau you can measure our
climate or e proteins and other things
so you can get a lot of proteomic data
from from the CSF and you can't get that
from the amyloid PET scan so the CSF
provides many proteins it's less
expensive there is this problem of
resistance the lumbar puncture and there
are some problems with immunoassays of
CSF a beta in tau which which caused
make a standardization problematic using
mass spec methods may be a help in this
area so this is some data from our lab
just showing the hippocampal volume
change over time and normal healthy
subjects and you can see that in Justin
normal people from agony you can see all
the raw data in all those colored lines
and the dark solid black line shows you
the mean and standard deviation of the
rate of change of hippocampal lying over
time so of course we're all interested
in the hippocampal volume is does
correlate with the memory decline and we
were interested in determining what are
the predictors or what are the various
covariates that affect the rate of
hippocampal atrophy and you can see here
that we looked at the effects of age
gender intracranial volume the gene
April e4 of the allele which is a risk
factor for Alzheimer's disease white
matter lesions measured t1 scan and
amyloid measured from chumma spinal
fluid measurement
so you can see that the the most
significant predictor was amyloid which
had a p-value of point 02 this shows you
the rate of hippocampal atrophy as a
function of age the black line are these
are all normal healthy subjects the
black line shows the normal subjects are
Emily negative and the red line shows
the normal subjects who are amyloid
positive and you can see that having
amyloid is associated with increased
rate of hippocampal atrophy the red
lines below the black line but if you
look on the scale on the left you see
that even people who are amyloid
negative are showing considerable
hippocampal atrophy over time and it
seems to increase with age so there are
factors that are causing brain atrophy
that are not directly related to amyloid
levels another way to look at all this
is to look at the different regions of
the brain and people are only positive
which would be out of left and the
healthy controls who are amyloid
negative on the right to see if the
regions are different that is does this
Alzheimer's pathology affect different
regions of the brain than normal aging
or to be seen similar patterns and the
answer I think is shown pretty well on
the slide that the reasons that you see
on the left hand column was a
hippocampus superior temporal middle
temporal superior frontal inferior
parietal and then if you go and you look
over on the right you see inferior
temple and literal temporal lateral
ventricle fusiform hippocampus those
same regions on the right are the
reasons you see on the left so what this
means is that as people get older there
are regions of the brain which are
shrinking especially around the
hippocampus and medial temporal lobe and
the amyloid increases the rate of
atrophy of these regions and this all
fits in with the idea that tau spreads
into the region around the hippocampus
and into rival cortex very early and is
accelerated by Alzheimer's disease this
is a slide showing some
diffusion tensor imaging results from
Paula Thompson's laboratory I don't have
time to go into all the details it's a
complicated slide but just to make the
point that we did a lot of DTI and a lot
of analysis for them by dr. Thompson and
that's available on the public website
this is a more data showing longitudinal
change of fractional anisotropy and
diffusivity from the DTI data and again
more data showing voxel based analysis
comparing the Alzheimer's disease
subjects versus controls showing the
regions of the brain where DTI tix
changes in patients with clinical
Alzheimer's disease and dr. Thompson's
laboratory has been mapping these group
differences on the fiber paths and found
that the measurements of mean
diffusivity gave a better effect size
seemed to be more sensitive than looking
at the fractional anisotropy but the
biggest changes being in the temporal
lobe which is of course where else I
murmurs disease is most prevalent and
here's some other connectivity graph
analysis work of this so there's a huge
amount of very very interesting various
types of image processing and analyses
that are done here's some the other work
that's going on is arterial spin label
perfusion MRI this is a technique where
the blood that flows into the brain is
labeled in the MRI machine and then a
scan is done of the brain and you can
determine the rate of blood flow into
the brain quite quantitatively by using
this method and here's a picture for
example of a healthy control subject on
the right a patient with Alzheimer's
disease on the left showing reduced flow
especially in the back of the brain
again I'm trying to to point an arrow to
this and not able to this is that
somehow working but at the bottom of the
brain you can see that the area is dark
reflecting reduced blood flow and
similarly the mci patient kind of is in
between the control
and the Alzheimer's patient so here is a
pretty complicated slide but i think
it's and this data just came out in the
paper by Nicholas Matson which is now
published in brain just came out this
week but basically what we're looking at
here is we're comparing we're looking at
the effects of a beta in normal subjects
in patients with early MC I'll nmci and
AD at the bottom and we're looking at
the effects of a beta and the n-terminal
cortex hippocampus inferior parietal and
you can see for example in the inferior
temporal region there is a quite a
substantial of the effect of a beta on
the perfusion is a point 25 effect size
that is one quarter of standard
deviation of the perfusion was was
reduced in the amyloid positive subjects
whereas if you look at the volume
affects the it's much smaller was only 0
point 0 4 of an effect size if you look
at the a bit effect in early mci the
next group down in yellow in the
inferior temporal cortex you see that
the the effect in the ASL is point two
eight where the effect on biome was only
point 02 well then when you get down to
the next group the the late MCI we begin
to see bigger changes in volume for
internal cortex if you this is the
orange colored if you go over to under
the volume you'll see point four seven
effect size but if you go under ASL it's
only point one four effect size so the
big message is that in the early stage
of the disease amai that seems to affect
profusion more than it affects volume
that is it doesn't produce atrophy but
in the later stage of the disease it
affects a atrophy greater than it
affects perfusion so there's a lot of
questions that we're still asking which
measurements best defined people who are
at risk for future cognitive decline and
progression to dementia age age is
definitely a factor it's the most
important factor genetics clearly is a
factor people with family histories have
greater rate of Alzheimer's disease and
they have a great proportion of
Alzheimer's disease and the April efore
gene accounts for some of the risk of
family history but it doesn't account
for all of the risk of family history
cardiovasc risk factors also seem to be
somewhat a risk for Alzheimer's but it's
not as less certain brain amyloid is
definitely a risk factor because if you
have brain amyloid you have Alzheimer's
disease brain atrophy in my view is
probably to nonspecific as a risk factor
but more work needs to be done and then
what is the role of ASL confusion DTI
resting state fMRI and now we have tau
imaging so television is the kind of a
hot new thing in our field despite the
new scientific information and
predictive value of amyloid PET scans
the truth is there is relatively poor
correlation between amyloid pet and the
clinical cognitive status for example as
I've already mentioned thirty percent of
normal healthy people in the 70s have
high amyloid now it's its associated
with more rapid cognitive decline but
you can have two people both aged 75 one
with dementia due to Alzheimer's disease
the other completely normal person and
they would have the same level of brain
amyloid so the correlation between
amyloid and clinical status is not so
good but it is known from pathology that
intracellular tau has a
higher correlation with clinical status
so most of what we know about how right
now comes from pathology studies and
pathology so here I've been instructed
to click on the arrow again and it
should work for each slide but it's not
working I'm doing something wrong so I
can't point so I'll just describe the
slide what we know from pathology is
kind of described here with the
so-called Brock staging Brock is a very
very famous pathologist in the
Alzheimer's field and what they're
saying is what Brock found is that
people who are normal elderly have low
levels of tau that's called stages one
and two but then in stages stage so I've
been instructed now to use the
whiteboard tools I'm trying to use the
whiteboard tools i click on white board
I'll click on it again then I click on
the arrow and still nothing come so I'm
definitely doing something wrong here
and I apologize that I can't use the
arrow to click seem to be working before
anyway the point is here that if you
look in the middle of these two there's
a if you look in the middle lower
picture you see a dark region on the
brain which describes the area around in
Toronto cortex and hippocampus and
that's where tau first begins to collect
in the very early stages of Alzheimer's
disease and that is why memory problems
occur early in Alzheimer's disease
Alzheimer's disease is predominantly not
exclusively a memory problem and that's
because the tau collects around the
internal cortex and hippocampus and
associated structures and then in later
stages of Brock stage five and six the
Tau spreads all throughout the whole
braid and the person gets progressively
demented but the problem is of our
knowledge now
comes from pathology studies Brock and
many many other people have written
papers but these are what type C studies
the people are often not seen clinically
sometimes for more than a year before
the autopsy and of course a lot of
things happen often around the time of
death which influence the quality of the
pathology so our knowledge about the
role of tau is limited but but there is
a sense that closely correlates with
clinical symptomatology so now I there's
been a lot of excitement in the field
and this is really what's hot right now
in 2014 about measuring tau in living
brain using pet ligands and there are
two pet Lincoln programs in humans well
there are more than two but two that
I've been talked about a lot one is a
program out of sendai japan at the
universe tokyo university professor dr.
Mora called thk 523 and 5105 and then
there's another group of compounds that
we developed initially by a heart with
coal that Siemens but now acquired by
avid which is a pathology which is a pet
ligand company which is now owned by
Lily called T 807 and T 808 so I'm going
to show you some of this data but i just
want to point out that the tau story is
a complicated story there are species of
town so called three or four hour so is
within cells whereas at what is outside
of cells but even though they have all
of these challenges here's some examples
of a towel pet scan from thk 5105 was
given to me by professor no Kimura and a
village and you see that a patient with
Alzheimer's disease who's in the lower
side who's more red there you could see
some red color where it is and that
could help you control above you only
see that red paying right in the in the
middle of the of the brain it's not
clear exactly what that means so there's
clearly differences between people with
Alzheimer's and healthy controls
and these investigators again showed
that in the patient with Alzheimer's you
see on the right a lot more involvement
of the brain that you see I'm a healthy
control on the left these investigators
have shown that that if you plot thk SUV
are that is the overall uptake of thk
against mini-mental state exam or the
clinic with dementia rating scale
episodic memory or non memory cognition
there's quite a good correlation that
you can see on the top so that's this is
extremely encouraging that the amount of
town in the brain correlates with the
degree of cognitive dysfunction and
here's another plot showing the
relationship of thk 523 to hippocampal
volume on the left you see there's a
good correlation but a very poor
correlation with the amount of amyloid
measured by PIP on the right so now I'm
going to show you some slides that come
from the avid company this is the the
compound T 807 developed by heart with
coal bed originally at siemens and
here's a group of subjects normal
control going from the left normal
control normal control nor control MCI
and AD and you can see that the normal
control subjects have very little towel
just maybe little blitz and there's some
arrows pointing to them but once you get
the MCI and AD you see a lot of red
appearing in the regions where we would
expect tau so this is a kind of very
exciting data the patient on the left is
a healthy control patient on the right
is a patient with Alzheimer's disease
with a mini mental state exam of 7 this
is a very demented subject you can see
that very very appears to be extensive
tower deposition another same case to
helping control on the left the patient
with amyloid disease on the right and
you can see that it's much more yellow
color and you're seeing accumulation in
the campus area and in other parts of
the brain as well here's a four
different subjects a healthy control a
patient with mild lipsy I patient with
mild
timers and severe Alzheimer's and you
can see this is a progression of more
and more Chow in these subjects these
investigators also looked at the
relationship of the Talib take to the
mini-mental state exam and you can see
there's pretty good correlations here
correlations of point nine point seven
these these are quite powerful we don't
see anything like this with amyloid so
the Chow is seems to relate closely the
symptomatology so therefore in summary
we think that these early preliminary
results is now probably less than 200
patients worldwide oven study are very
promising and we can expect an explosion
of new data so we're very interested in
what happens to people are my positive
and how much that we see people arrival
a negative and what is the use of all of
this in a clinical trials would this be
a sensitive outcome measure with the if
a treatment slow the progression of tau
spread would that be something that we
could use a so-called a validated
surrogate a validated surrogate is
something that everybody would like to
see for clinical trials because a
validated surrogate would replace
clinical outcomes so you would not
necessarily need to demonstrate that
your treatment slowed cognition or
function you could simply show if this
was a validated surrogate you could show
that if your treatment slowed the
progression of tau the regulators and
the scientific community would agree
that you're really slowing the
progression of Alzheimer's disease so
these are are very interesting questions
which we hope to to be addressing an ad
me because we're right now seeking
funding to do tap a scanning in the
enemy project so changing gears a little
bit here we've been collecting a DNA for
those of you who have any interest in
genetics there's a tremendous amount of
genetics information available in Adney
initially we did hold we did what's
called G wasps and so
gee I sent every subject is available in
the database is available right now well
in addition thanks to the rajini
wojcicki bryn foundation and the
Alzheimer's Association and we are able
to do whole genome sequencing of the DNA
of 800 Adney subjects and the results
have now been available at an old slide
it was also been available since last
summer it's the largest whole genome
sequencing study done of Alzheimer's
disease and of course all of the data is
available to the the community so this
is every single base pair sequence in
these 800 subjects it's a treasure trove
of data and we're very excited about the
results and we haven't yet seen any
papers coming out of this but this is
going to happen very soon so another
point to make about this project is the
data sharing that we as I've emphasized
for all of the data that's collected in
that knee that is all the raw data all
the processed data all the clinical data
the calculated data the imaging data the
G wash data the see what the CSF amyloid
and tau etc proteomics it's all there on
the internet in a huge database at the
that should be USC Roni agni if is dr.
toga move to USC so I've got the URL
wrong on this slide and many people
around the world have taken this data
written papers and we have well right
now actually more than 500 manuscripts
should have published the best slice a
little outdated as well and this was
unprecedented data sharing is really a
model for future science we would like
to see more and more projects especially
big projects and small projects once
people get their papers out we'd like to
see people sharing data on the internet
so that other scientists can take
advantage of the data leading to more
discovery and more rapid advances
another thing I want to mention that
something called the worldwide Adney the
world why daddy is I mean I've been only
describing to you the result
in the United States and Canada call
that North American add me and I showed
you briefly some results from Australia
but there's ad knees in Japan Korea
China Europe and South America and
everybody is working together and the
data is being collected on the eloni
database and this is a very exciting
thing to create a worldwide community of
investigators we're using the same
methods and sharing data this will
greatly facilitate international
clinical trials wanna point out that
Andy is funded by the national institute
of aging and if you want to learn more
about acne you can go to our website at
neath dash info Oh RG that doesn't have
the data that's just an information site
it has all of the protocol also has the
grants that we wrote it has the names of
the investigators it posts slides from
our various meetings so it's basically
if you want to get involved in learning
more about acne you could go to that
website there's also a there have been
to review articles that we published
which review all of the papers and
adding at a very thorough away so you
can if you want to quickly see who's
done what and and what information has
been cleaned you can go to these review
articles and then if it gets your own
idea to do something new that you can go
to the add new database and analyze data
and write a paper and what we love it so
these are the industry partners who are
supporting about thirty percent of the
funds to add me through something called
the foundation for NIH we're greatly
indebted to them for their support and
we have something called the private
partner scientific board which meets
monthly to discuss the use of biomarkers
for a for Alzheimer's clinical trials so
again you can see these slides I'll put
all the slides up on the website and you
can you can go to the the
USC a database to get the emulator so
and then if you want to get your CME
credits for this talk you go to this
site and now we're at the last slide so
at this point I'm going to go over and
see who's as for questions I was told to
click on this QA so we have quite a
large number of questions let me just
get a sense of how many we have ok so
I'll I'll just start taking the
questions one by one as they come in and
then if I think we're probably going to
have time to discuss these questions and
even take some more so if there is any
of you have questions for me about add
me or about Alzheimer's disease in
general or the use of imaging for
neurodegenerative disease I'd be happy
to to address them so the first question
is have you ever seen the data on
hippocampal volume and meditation
practice in the alternative medicine
field and I think that this person is
citing a some specific paper or maybe
not so the answer is yes there are there
are there's there's a whole world of
data showing the effects of a lot of
different things on hippocampal volume
uh the the the probably one of the most
interesting studies the cut this all
started with some work that was done
from England where people showed that
taxi drivers were studied for the London
taxi exam had a bigger hippocampus that
people who didn't study for the taxi
exam and cystic the campus is involved
with memory this has been taken to me
that there's some plasticity going on
perhaps growth of new neurons or
increase in size of neurons that is
coupled to all of that the memory work
that people did to study for the exam
since then there have been many studies
that have shown the benefits of many
things on brain volumes and exercises
won various types of cognitive training
has been used various medication
been shown to a constant change in
various parts of the brain and also have
seen some work on meditation practice
having a beneficial effect so the next
question I'm clicking on is what is the
role played by enzymes like inositol and
nice and tall and triphosphate 3-kinase
be in human brain and Alzheimer's
disease I don't know the answer to that
inositol is not an enzyme nos told is a
compound it's involved in signaling
pathways and Milan acetal which is one
form of the sugar at us at all does seem
to be elevated in Alzheimer's disease
but exactly what the role is of these
enzymes is I this is not an area of my
expertise sorry I can give you a better
answer so the next question is what is
the mechanism behind amyloid beta and
tau protein proliferation and let me
click on this I am only seeing part of
the question it says what is the
mechanism behind amyloid beta and tau
protein proliferation is it possible to
use amino acid or enzymes to what I
can't see the rest of it ok so anyway
I'll answer well first of all nobody
knows that mech the answer to the
question up between why we see a
proliferation of these proteins but we
we have part of the answer there is a
disorder called early onset familial
Alzheimer's disease which is a very
strongly genetic form of Alzheimer's
disease that affects families and people
develop in their their their early age
and so in those cases there is a gene
mutation that causes increased
amyloid-beta production but in old
people who get Alzheimer's disease it's
a little less certain whether or not is
increased production or perhaps
decreased clearance of amyloid that
results
in the amyloid accumulating and amyloid
plaques being formed but there's a lot
of interest in this because if we
understood the mechanism by why these
neon white went up then we could develop
treatments that were aimed at that
mechanism so that's an area of a lot of
research what is the mechanism between
Chow protein proliferation again it's
really not known there's something about
the interaction between amyloid and tau
once people start getting emily in their
brain its causes how to proliferate but
we don't know why one thing that's been
of great interest to people lately is
the idea that these proteins these are
miss folded proteins and that they seem
to spread along the neuron and jump from
one neuron to another neuron almost in
like that in an infectious way almost
like a prion and this is a lot of
research is being done right now on
what's called themselves to sell
transmission of amyloid and tau and some
people are trying to develop treatments
including anybody's that would block
selfi cell transformation so it's an
area for a lot of research it's not that
an area where I have huge expertise so
is it the question now I see the full
question at the bottom is it possible to
use amino acid or enzymes to break down
these proteins I don't really know the
answer to that one of the major ways
that people have been trying to get at
the proteins is to use antibodies and
the anybody's can come from either what
we call active immunization that is
using like a vaccine and that that was
one of the really very famous
observations that was made by DL shank
and published in science you know 15
years ago that if you inject amyloid
protein into a mice that are making
amyloid in their brain may anybody's
that are generated in the mice will
cause the the plaques to go away so
there had been attempts to to do
clinical trials with vaccines the first
one unfortunately had a lot of side
effects and people who are very badly
hurt by it so they had a
continue the trial most of the
approaches these days have been with
monoclonal antibodies that are aimed at
a beta but another approach is to use a
small molecules which inhibit the
synthesis of a beta we call them secret
ace inhibitors because we know that
there's a beta secretase in the gamma
secretase were involved in the synthesis
of of amyloid protein so the next
question is I note that the controls the
tau kept looking images are not aged
match to the MCI and AD examples these
tau Liggins patent as they tend to
increase and images with subjects age
it's a very very good question that you
know the images that I've shown you are
very very early a kind of proof of
concept images so i don't really know
the answer to the question we certainly
expect based on the pathology that young
people are going to have very little tau
in their brain and then as people get
older going to see more and more tau and
locus coeruleus and the transcend
toronto cortex n-terminal cortex
hippocampus temporal cortex and as
people develop our way to the brain and
have alzheimer's disease there's going
to be a much more rapid spread of tau
throughout the rest of the brain but we
just don't know keith johnson at the
Massachusetts General Hospital is right
now it's done 40 or 50 studies and
everybody's ready here to see what his
results look like avid pharmaceutical it
is going to be distributing their child
ligand over the next month's to some
sites so this is really hot everybody
who is interested in imaging and
clinical Alzheimer's disease is thinking
and planning of how they can start doing
cow PET scanning because there's going
to be a lot honest it's it's certainly
going to result in a lot of papers we're
going to learn a lot more about the
physiology of the disease but more
importantly it's potentially a very good
outcome measure for clinical trials and
that's because in contrast to
Alzheimer's contrast in amyloid beta tau
really correlates with symptoms so if
you slow
look the spread of tau probably you're
going to slow the spread of symptoms
that's what we would expect and how you
would slow the spread of tau well
perhaps drugs aid that amyloid will slow
the spread of town because certainly the
presence of amyloid facilitates the
spread of tau but people are starting to
develop treatments which are aimed
specifically at app so it's just very
very exciting the next slide is what are
my thoughts about Auto antibodies as
diagnostic markers of mci or ad well my
thoughts are this is a great thing to do
and there are quite a number of papers
about what I'm antibodies are going up
in people with Alzheimer's disease and
the auto antibodies may be diagnostic
markers the auto antibodies might also
be depending on what they want
antibodies to they may be actually
working to slow the progression or speed
the progression of the disease so I
think it's a terrific target and I think
there have been some encouraging reports
but they of course they always need to
be replicated and that's the problem
with all the blood tests involved in
Alzheimer's disease we have seen Barry's
papers get published where people claim
to have good test but then it never gets
replicated so in science you have to
have replication and replication and
replication so the planning can be
ultimately generalized the possible
effects of DHA supplementation megha
three special i would say that there are
possible effects there are a wide
variety of a certain literature I think
that the overall I think it's fair to
say that people who from very early life
have been eating a lot of fish oil all
their lives they seem to have a lower
incidence of Alzheimer's disease but
it's not so clear you start taking fish
oil as an adult it's really going to
reduce your risk for Alzheimer's disease
the epidemiology studies show
associations but that's not the same as
doing a randomized clinical trial
and some small trials have been
encouraging but I think it's I think
it's fair to say that right now the the
evidence is not strong enough that you
could just routinely tell people they
should be taking tha although there are
a lot of benefits acclaim for other
things for DHA so it's it's associated
news cardiovascular risk and software so
any idea why they hippocampus and
anti-rattle cortex are the first
structures to be affected the answer is
basically no we just don't know there is
some suggestion from Brock that tau
originates in the locus coeruleus and
then is a pathway from the locus
coeruleus to the entire cortex to the
campus and tau those along that pathway
but basically in the whole field of
neurodegenerative diseases which we have
Alzheimer's disease of course which
affects memory and causes dementia
affected with amyloid encou then you
have Parkinson's disease which is
another neurodegenerative disease that's
associated with alpha synuclein protein
that affects the substantial [ __ ] and
the basal ganglia and produces shaking
and rigidity and difficulty walking and
then there's a mitropa lateral sclerosis
which affects the motor system and
causes paralysis and death so there's
nui body disease which is associated
with elucidation Xand cognition problems
it's also caused by alpha synuclein
accumulation but each of these disorders
is associated with a different system
ALS affects the motor system Alzheimer's
disease affects the memory system
Parkinson's disease affects the motor
system and balance and we do not know
why these proteins tend to collect in
these specific networks or reasons of
the brain so next question is
Alzheimer's disease atrophy progression
rate fan related with any influencing
factor uh
well people who are amyloid the positive
people have a void in their brain
certainly have a more rapid rate of
progression than people who don't have
amyloid in their brain even though the
people are diagnosed clinically with
Alzheimer's disease so if we call
Alzheimer's disease progression the the
group of people who are diagnosed with
Alzheimer's disease clinically yes it's
clear that having having my than the
brain is associated with a more rapid
progression and brain atrophy I think a
cerebrovascular disease has also been
shown to increase the rate of brain
atrophy maybe the amount of white matter
lesions but I I think that's more seen
in normals and not so much seen in
people with Alzheimer's dementia I don't
know if a polly for is associated with a
more rapid progression they just can't
remember that I'm sure there are papers
that are written on that so I'm trying
to think of what other influencing
factors there are age is an influencing
factor and I think of as people get
older like you get into their navies the
rate of change is slower that is in
general people no clinically it's really
interesting about Alzheimer's disease
they know where you are when you get it
and we're rapid the progression if you
get it in your 40s it's a very rapid
progression if you get in your 50s it's
still pretty fast in 60s it's slower in
70s it's slower by the time people get
into their 90's if they have Alzheimer's
disease the rate of progression is very
slow why older age is associated with
the slower rate of progression is a big
mystery next question astrocytes can be
activated to help clean clean up tau
tangles it's a good idea the danger is
that if you activate the astrocytes or
the microglia they can produce adverse
effects as well because we know that in
diseases like multiple sclerosis and
hiv/aids there is activation of the
oligodendrocytes and
that is responsible for symptoms so one
has to be very careful about trying to
develop approaches to clean out a boy
and clean out ow because these
approaches can have kind of you know can
have negative side effects so I think
that we're coming to the end of the
questions as far as I can see and we
finish a little early I think that
usually people don't objective into
finishing early so I think I thank you
all for listening from the talk I hope
it's been helpful and I wish you all
lots of luck bye bye